bonjour à tous bienvenue dans parlement
hebdo toute l'actualité politique et
parlementaire avec mme moracchini
bonjour jour michael bonjour à tous dans
l'actualité cette semaine on vous en
parle depuis des semaines cette fois
c'est fait louis gallois a remis son
rapport sur la compétitivité il prône un
choc de confiance de près de 30
milliards d'euros le lendemain jean marc
ayrault annoncé les mesures du
gouvernement et notamment contre toute
attente une rose de la tva le mariage
homosexuel adoptée en conseil des
ministres un texte qui augure de débats
houleux en janvier prochain dans
l'hémicycle en attendant les députés ont
commencé les auditions à l'assemblée
nationale il y à du rififi chez les
alliés des socialistes au sénat les
communistes ont voté contre la loi de
programmation budgétaire pour les cinq
prochaines années
le premier ministre les a reçus à
matignon mais ne cède rien chez les
verts on s'interroge de plus en plus sur
la participation au gouvernement est
avec nous pour commenter l'actualité
eric woerth bonjour et merci d'être avec
nous sur ce plateau député ump de l'oise
ancien ministre du budget puis du
travail dans le gouvernement fillon
vous allez donc pouvoir commenter avec
nous ce fameux pacte de compétitivité
dérouler cette semaine auparavant c'est
la coutume dans cette émission fait un
petit tour aux quatre colonnes on est
allé demander à vos collègues ce qu'il
avait à dire sur vous et c'est elisa
bartholomé qui est allé cette semaine en
garde
exact
de qualité c'est un homme intelligent
c'est un homme attentif aux autres
je dois dire pour être le porte parole
du peuple npa la commission des finances
que je peux attester de la constance et
de l'intensité de son travail à la
commission
nous apprécions tant que ministre
courageux il a fait travailler dans
l'oeil de retraite j'ai souffert en même
temps que lui
des attaques violentes dont et elle a
été l'objet je trouve ça dommage pour
les hommes de cette qualité pense que
c'est quelqu'un qui qui mérite une autre
notre amitié pour ce qu'il est pour la
compétence qu'il a je le dis jamais le
d'appréciation personnelle sur les
hommes politiques je lutte contre leur
politique d'eric woerth
pourquoi il ya une vote qu'est ce qu'il
a fait aujourd'hui j'ai
vraiment une amitié pour lui
indépendamment du fait qu'il est maire
de chantilly et moins de maisons
laffitte et qu'à nous deux on est je
dirais la mafia du cheval voilà en
filigrane on a vu beaucoup même vos
collègues l'ump vos amis et vous quand
même les affaires même en vous posant
parfois comme présentant comme victime
ou au contraire l affaire bettencourt
bien sûr est ce que ça vous empêche
parfois de faire sereinement votre
métier de député quand comme ça dans le
regard de vos collègues vous voyez
parfois écrit affaires mises en examen
souffrance personnelle du personnel ça
nécessite ça exige aussi une sorte
d'auto d'autolimitation à certains
moments vous réfréner sur un sujet vous
obliger à ne pas répondre non je n'ai
pas d'exemple possible j'aurais pu
défendre
la première motion du groupe sur la loi
de finances rectificative à de finances
rectificative du mois de juillet je ne
les ai pas fait parce que je me suis dit
que si je montais en pression dans le
domaine de l'opposition je risquais de
faire déraper les choses devant beaucoup
de députés que c'était pas c'était pas
souhaitable pour l'ump elle même donc je
remercie pour vous même pour votre
carrière politique
écoutez c'est pas très agréable d'autant
plus que je considère que tout ça est
très très un juge jeudi depuis deux ans
deux ans et demi mais voilà c'est comme
ça
mais d'un autre côté c'est du personnel
et et j'ai décidé de me battre et je le
fais depuis deux heures et demie et il
ya toujours aucune preuve d'ailleurs une
peut y en avoir aucune qui justement va
être entendu par le juge gentil très
prochainement est ce que finalement ce
n'est pas quelque chose qui vous soulage
puisque vous n'êtes plus vraiment en
première ligne je commenterai pas ça
parce qu'il ya une instruction amour
l'instruction une construction des comme
ça à des propos des articles de journaux
volés des pv d'audition de sa volée ça
tout ça est très désagréable et en même
temps moi j'ai décidé de consacrer ma
vie à la vie politique et j'ai pas
décidé de l'arrêter comme ça sinon
j'aurais arrêté et des la retraite
dell à la retraite
mais bella fans d'abord si j'aurais pu
m'arrêter avant la réforme des retraites
c'est ce que au fond tout le monde a
essayé de faire en essayant de
l'expulser au travers d'un d'un lynchage
médiatique absolument incroyable bien
supérieur à celui que subit aujourd'hui
françois hollande ou d'autres et puis
que j'ai pas décidé ça donc je décide et
continuelle j'étais sur la vie politique
continue et vous allez avec nous et
continuer les actions dans cette vie
politique ça va commencer donc avec le
lundi on en a beaucoup parlé il est là
il est tout chaud le rapport gallois 22
propositions pour relancer la
compétitivité après des semaines de
spéculations le rapport gallois est
enfin rendue publique l'ancien patron de
ads préconisa choc de compétitivité
synonyme de choc de confiance tous les
détails avec sophie normand la
préconisation la plus importante du
rapport concerne le coût du travail
louis gallois préconise une baisse des
charges en deux ans maximum 20 milliards
de baisse des cotisations patronales
plus 10 milliards de baisse des
cotisations salariales des baisses qui
ne ciblerait pas que les bas salaires
mais s'appliquerait également à ce
représentant jusqu'à 3,5 fois le smic
le rapport recommande aussi le
renforcement des filières industrielles
il faudrait conditionner les soutiens de
l'état aux actions des grandes
entreprises à leur capacité à y associer
leurs fournisseurs et sous traitants
le commissaire à l'investissement
préconise un soutien plus efficace à
l'exportation et propose la lune dans
des conditions des crédits garantis
export sur le meilleur niveau constaté
chez les concurrents parmi les autres
préconisations un small business act
pour les pme donner plus de poids aux
représentants des salariés dans les
conseils d'administration des
entreprises de plus de 5000 salariés
doubler les contrats en alternance en
cinq ans ou encore reprendre les
recherches sur les gaz de schiste devine
ou presque ce que vous allez nous dire
c'est que sera pas très bien mais vous
auriez également sait tous que tout ce
qui a été préconisé vous l'auriez
adoptez vous aussi quand il aura
beaucoup de rapports avant le rapport de
louis gallois donc il
notamment un rapport parlementaire qui
n'est jamais sorti entre l'opposition et
la majorité quelques mois avant
l'élection présidentielle
la croyez cahuzac méhaignerie je faisais
partie de cette commission
on n'a pas réussi à sortir un rapport
commun pour des raisons d'appréciation
sur les 35 heures mais qu'on sur leur
dos les mesures de louis gallois étaient
là je remarque que c'est pas un rapport
très original
la plupart des poinçons sont bien connus
il al'avantage de venir au bon moment et
nous avons nous mis beaucoup la pression
dans l'opposition pour dire la
compétitivité c'est c'est la première
des priorités c'était celle du
gouvernement de nicolas sarkozy c'est la
première des priorités du gouvernement
qu'ils soient de droite ou qu'ils soient
de gauche et ça ça a été beaucoup nié
alors louis gallois c'est un peu une
bouée de sauvetage
c'est un peu un nouveau gourou pour le
gouvernement je vais le président le
président le premier ministre et rod
arrêtait pas de parler de gallois
gallois gallois ont fait plus que
gallois en fait - gallois enfin galop et
demi oui mais c'est apparu en réalité le
gouvernement en donnant le sentiment
qu'il n'appliquerait pas du tout le
rapport gallois qu'ils enterraient avant
la fin ce qui n'a pas été le cas en
réalité est est apparu comme finalement
assez active dans ses propositions tout
simplement parce que comme même très
mauvais élèves dont on n'y va jamais
rentrer de coop il en rend quand même
une on se dit quand même c'est pas si
mal
enfin un mot sur les 35 heures n'ont ce
rapport ne regrette pas un mot sur les
35 heures ici très dommageable puisque
on considère que la réduction comme ça
du temps de travail a été le premier
facteur de décrochage de la
compétitivité française aujourd'hui
comme on l'a connu à peu près par par
tout le monde et puis y'a pas grand
chose sur les dépenses même si louis
gallois en parle il n'y a pas grand
chose sur la dépense publique qui en
réalité la première des mesures à
prendre pour améliorer la compétitivité
du pays c'est à dire baisser la dépense
publique trop de dépenses publiques 55
56 % en dépenses publiques sur le coût
du travail
je pense que le pain lutter contre le pl
perte de compétitivité du pays
c'est d'abord de faire baisser la
dépense publique on consacre un moment
donné trop de dépenses lui plus de la
moitié des dépenses par rapport à notre
richesse nationale est une dépense
publique à venir faisait pas une dépense
privée donc sa vie d'accès pas de
l'investissement et ça concourt pas au
partage des richesses c'est évidemment
beaucoup trop mais dans le rapport aux
gallois il ya plein de choses qui nous
montrait
bien il parle de tva il parle de coût du
travail est d'ailleurs c'est
complètement artificielle de vouloir
séparer le coup la compétitivité coût de
la compétitivité hors coûts si vous
n'avez pas de compétitivité coûts
l'entreprise elle fait de moins en mois
de marche et louis gallois le dit très
bien les marges des entreprises se
réduit sont traîtres sont beaucoup plus
faibles que dans d'autres pays d'europe
et donc vous n'avez pas les moyens de
faire de la recherche de faire de
l'innovation de vous projeter sur le
plan marketing de faire de l'export etc
vous n'avez pas les moyens de le faire
donc d'abord la compétitivité coût
évidemment le reste mais le reste est
très consensuel entre nous qu'on fasse
de la formation de la recherche de
l'innovation
on va voir ce que le gouvernement a fait
ce rapport
réponse dès le lendemain mardi qu'elle
allait vite le rapport aux gallois n'a
donc pas été un énième rapport enterré
on l'a dit un séminaire gouvernemental
se tient à matignon dès ce mardi pour
décider des suites à lui apporter ces
mêmes jean marc ayrault en personne qui
présente ce pacte de compétitivité et il
y a bien sûr un peu de rapports gallois
même beaucoup dans ce pacte elisa
bartholomé contrairement à ce que
disaient les rumeurs le gouvernement
s'est donc largement inspiré du rapport
gallois est d'abord de sa mesure phare
la baisse du coût du travail chiffré à
20 milliards d'euros
elle s'étalera sur trois ans les
salaires ne seront pas directement
concernés cette baisse prendra la forme
d'un crédit d'impôt indexé sur la masse
salariale des entreprises
il portera sur les salaires compris
entre 1 et 2 5 fois le smic
cela représentera l'équivalent d'une
baisse de 6 % du coût du travail
autrement dit plus une entreprise
emploiera de personnes paient moins de
deux fois et demie le smic plus la
réduction d'impôt sera importante
l'état devra bien sûr compenser cette
baisse de recettes deux solutions sont
retenus par jean marc ayrault 10
milliards de réduction des dépenses
publiques et 10 milliards de hausses
d'impôts via la fiscalité écologique est
l'augmentation modérée de la tva le
gouvernement proposera en effet que le
taux intermédiaire qui portent notamment
sur la restauration et les travaux de
rénovation des logements
rapporté à 7% de 7% aujourd'hui à 10% et
que le taux normal soit portée de 19,6 à
20% pour faire passer la pilule le
gouvernement diminuera le taux réduit de
tva de 5,5 à 5 % sur les produits
alimentaires et l'énergie
ces augmentations ne prendront pas effet
tout de suite la hausse de la tva est
prévue au 1er janvier 2014
la fiscalité écologique sera elle mise
en place en 2016
alors il ya quand même des ré des
différences très notable un notamment
louis gallois préconisait une baisse des
cotisations pour les entreprises se sont
finalement c'est finalement l'impôt sur
les sociétés qui sera baissée oui la
mise en oeuvre par le gouvernement si le
verre à moitié vide ou à moitié plein
dit jean marc ayrault quand il présente
à l'air de s'ennuyer
c'est profondément bien que ces
contourner le problème
d'abord c'est pas 30 puisque louis
gallois
me louis belleau a ravagé la descente du
monde économique dit il faut au moins 30
milliards d'euros si on veut qu'ils
aient une signification bien on était
nous on avait commencé à faire 13 et
l'idée c'était de poursuivre vous et 13
en une fois une année dès cette année
bon on est de louis gallois dit il faut
30 et je pense que la plupart des
économistes disent il faut entre 20 et
50 milliards d'euros de transferts de
charge du travail vers vers d'autres
enfin d'allègements de charges ou fond
sur le travail et est passé par un
crédit d'impôt
c'est très compliqué en réalité car si
on considère que le coût du travail
c'est l'essentiel du problème ce qui est
le cas en france le coût du travail
c'est des salaires et des charges à
baisser les salaires
oui mais c'est une mesure fiscale c'est
une niche fiscale c'est pas la baisse
des charges - la baisse des charges
c'est clair et puis on n'y revient pas
entre serrar d'augmenter les charges
sociales une fois qu'on les a baissé
pour cette raison de tunis fiscales donc
soumise à l'avis un peu mouvementée des
niches fiscales puis c'est pas non plus
grand c'est pas non plus un investisseur
étranger comme il y en a beaucoup
j'espère qu'ils regardent la
compétitivité des pays regarde le coût
du travail et la niche fiscale la baisse
de l'impôt sur les sociétés elle ne
rentrera pas dans cette analyse sur la
baisse du coût du travail car elle est
très éloigné la baisse du coût du
travail
c'est pas mal
- 20 milliards sur la fiscalité des
entreprises c'est très bien mais c'est
un peu quand même
sapeur camembert il ya on a dans ce
budget augmenter les impôts des
entreprises d'une quinzaine de milliards
quand on prend le collectif de juillet
et puis le budget 2013
et puis au mois de novembre on baisse on
dit qu'on va baisser de 20 milliards et
tout ça dans un délai un calendrier qui
n'est pas le bon
il ya un calendrier qui doit être
l'urgence en réalité toutes ces mesures
sont remises à 2014 voire à 2016 pour la
fiscalité écologique choisir tes bien
que vous en pensez eric woerth a été
monté et descendu pour certaines
notamment pour les débats sur les
produits de première nécessité est ce
que c'est la bonne fourchette est ce que
c'est bien souvent qu'on a d'abord c'est
bien de passer par la tva je crois que
c'est bien nous on a arrêté jeudi s'ils
ne connaissent pas la tva sociale c'est
la même chose c'est la tva sociale mais
c'est une fois si vous reprenez les
déclarations lumière ministre socialiste
du premier ministre comme du président
de la république sur la tva sociale et
que vous regardez aujourd'hui ce qu'ils
font enfin où vous mourrez de rire ou
vous ou dit dans quel monde je vis donc
évidemment la tva sociale c'est une très
bonne idée c'est ce qu'il fallait faire
les allemands l'avaient fait et nous le
font si oui c'est bien mais c'est pas
assez
la tva va jouer à peu près à hauteur de
6 à 7 milliards d'euros
dans ce transfert de charges transférées
de 20 milliards
donc il ya une autre partie sur les
dépenses publiques mais on ne sait pas
sur quoi et ça doit se rajouter à
l'effort de dépenses publiques lui doit
contribuer à l'équilibré des finances
publiques est pas au financement de
transfert de charme et sur la fiscalité
écologique sûr on n'en sait rien oui
c'est mieux de ne pas toucher la csg
parce que la cgl impacte directement le
pouvoir d'achat mais sur la tva au lieu
d'avoir bien 1.6 que nous mettions
notamment sur le taux normal sur les
19,6 parce que ça permet d'être
concentré beaucoup l'effort sur des
importations qui elle souvent
contiennent du travail du dumping social
au fond qu'on importe
en france on augmente fortement l'un des
taux réduit c'est à dire de cette on
passe à dix pour beaucoup beaucoup de
services qui vont toucher beaucoup
beaucoup de catégories moyennes de
français et je pense que c'est une
erreur de ventilation importante mais
passer par la tva c'est bien mieux que
de passer par là siège sans doute dans
l'hémicycle mardi après midi bien sûr
toutes ces questions étaient
relayée dans l'hémicycle en ce mardi sur
quinze questions au gouvernement à dix
sont portés sur la compétitivité et
chants juifs tels ceux questions
réponses entre un député ump et le
ministre de l'économie
vous ne suivez pas ce rapport
contrairement à ce que vous avez dit
monsieur le premier ministre
vos décisions ne sont absolument pas à
la hauteur des enjeux
au lieu de baisser massivement et
immédiatement les charges des
entreprises
vous nous sortez du chapeau une nouvelle
usine à gaz bureaucratique estampillé
socialiste le crédit d'impôt pourquoi
faire simple quand on peut faire
compliqué on ne peut pas s'empêcher à
dire vrai de sourire quand on vous
entend parler de compétitivité parce que
comme l'a dit le premier ministre lisez
ce rapport gallois que vous vantez temps
ce n'est pas seulement un diagnostic
c'est un réquisitoire un réquisitoire
contre ce que vous l'avez pas fait de
réquisitoire contre l'état du pays tel
que vous le laissez les vous sentir un
peu visé contre ce réquisitoire a été
mise du budget 3 ans donc par exemple la
tva sociale n'a été imaginé que dans le
dernier mois avant la présidentielle ce
qui fâche le score
j'ai en fait l'histoire la tva sociale
et l'état chez elle et s est longue on
peut remonter les élections législatives
de janvier recèlent en mai en 2002 qui
en 2012 et est largement plébiscité le
problème de compétitivité on le tire
depuis depuis longtemps ce problème de
compétitivité les salaires ont augmenté
en france plus vite qu'en allemagne
depuis et pendant en se disant oui bien
sûr évidemment évidemment mais les
socialistes doivent tenir compte et tout
cela ils doivent dire n'aurait pas dû
augmenter les salaires autant ils disent
jamais touche là au fond ils ont
participé à tout cela les syndicats ont
participé à tout cela les chefs
d'entreprise ont participé toute la nous
ce qu'on a fait sur les cinq ans en tout
cas de nicolas sarkozy on s'est battu
contre la crise
la réalité elle est là parce qu'elle est
totalement oubliée donc c'était très
difficile de faire la tva sociale ou
compétitivité quelle que soit la manière
dont on l'appelle ou anti délocalisation
c'était très difficile de le faire en
plein coeur de crise on était à -2%
le nom n'est plus au fond de crise c'est
plus facile de gouverner aujourd'hui que
de gouverner à l'époque de mire la
sarkozie écoutez les réactions aussi
dans la majorité à la gauche du parti
socialiste
vous allez voir vous n'êtes pas les
seuls non plus à dire que ces réformes
ne sont pas les bonnes
écoutez le débat est installé dans la
majorité puisque vous savez que nous
nous nous faisons des propositions
alternatives à celles du gouvernement et
malheureusement les annonces de ce matin
on rajoute dans une dans un cap qui à
nos yeux ne permettra pas de sortir de
la crise est-ce que cet entre-deux
suscite un réel mécontentement pas
encore mais c'est vrai que cette
impression de lisibilité voire des
incohérences par rapport à ce qui se
faisait en juillet et qui est concret y
compris quelque part il n'ya manque
d'orientation stratégique et un manque
de cap et voilà sept
en vérité je suis inquiet j'avais
entendu jean vincent placé jeudi à qui
il va même plus loin en ce vendredi le
besoin de la question des ministres au
sein du gouvernement est ce qu'ils
doivent garder leur place ou pas ils ont
un problème dans leur majorité ils y
apprennent avec les verts eric woerth
enfin le gouvernement change d'avis tout
le temps sur la tva il a changé d'avis
tout en vous reprenez les verbatim de ce
qui a été dit a encore quelques semaines
et voilà donc ya pas de conviction au
fond c'est ça qui est inquiétant parce
que changer d'avis tout le temps ça veut
dire qu'on va continuer à changer des
vies alors qu'on a besoin d'un cap très
fort on n'a pas voté au sénat le groupe
ump en même temps que les sociétés les
communistes mais pour d'autres raisons
la loi de programmation dans la
programmation aucun problème avec la
gauche de la gauche très net on le voit
bien à l'assemblée puis à un problème
avec les verts ça c'est évident les
verts n'existe plus il n'existe plus il
ya eu une proposition en verte
y'a pas d'initiative des verts dans ce
débat budgétaire très fort que nous
avons aujourd'hui
où est la parole des verts dans le sujet
très très important qui suit la
fiscalité écologique
le gouvernement dit en 2007 2
on peut être une fiscalité écologique la
même fiscalité écologique d'ailleurs la
taxe carbone a été retoquée par le
conseil constitutionnel
à la demande du groupe socialiste
donnant un autre à notre époque
donc les verts et là dedans qui était
gouvernement eric woerth ça c'est leur
problème je ne peux pas du tout le dire
tout ce que je sais c'est qu'ils sont
extraordinairement maltraités unis
n'agissent sur rien le parti socialiste
de l'eure la cible leur départ même
s'ils ne le souhaitent pas donc ça
laisse une porte ouverte
c'est absolument énorme ça montre que
les ministres verts ne servent à rien et
ça montre que le les verts aujourd'hui
ne servent à rien ne note aucun impact
sur l'évolution la politique du
gouvernement aujourd'hui ils sont
considérés comme partie très minoritaire
delà de la majorité et c'est très
humiliant à mon avis quand on est vert
aujourd'hui de faire partie du
gouvernement
où est la parole des verts moi je dis la
fiscalité écologique est un élément
probablement majeure l'évolution de
notre fiscalité nous avons essayé nous
n'y avons pas réussi à cause du parti
socialiste j'aurais bien aimé que dans
ce débat budgétaire les verts nous dise
un peu comment peu s'orchestrer
s'articuler une fiscalité écologique
moderne dans notre pays ils ont
complètement raté ce débat est au fond
des socialistes en sont certainement
très très heureux allez on va passer au
mercredi barack obama
once again et parmi les défis qui
attendent barack obama y en a qui sera
de taille va devoir gérer une majorité
républicaine au congrès qui l'a ralenti
qui l'a empêchée pendant ces quatre
dernières années le récit de simo
barbarie mardi soir les américains ont
élu un président mais pas seulement
comme tous les deux ans ce sont un tiers
des sièges du sénat et la totalité des
sièges de la chambre des représentants
qui ont été renouvelés l'enjeu du
scrutin est de taille car barack obama a
besoin du soutien des deux chambres du
congrès pour faire passer des réformes
urgentes au sénat tout d'abord les
démocrates obtiennent 55 sièges sur 101
suffisant pour avoir la majorité fixé à
60 voix il s'expose ainsi à une possible
obstruction parlementaire pire à la
chambre des représentants les
républicains gardent leur majorité
acquise en 2010
cette cohabitation pourrait se
transformer en catastrophe économique
les membres de la chambre des
représentants ont jusqu'à la fin de
l'année pour se mettre d'accord sur des
réformes destinées à réduire la dette
publique
une dette estimée à plus de 16 milliards
de dollars
l'urgence est telle que le candidat
défait mitt romney a appelé à l'unité
lors de son discours de défaite si aucun
accord bi partisan n'est conclu la
première puissance mondiale pourrait
alors se retrouver en défaut de paiement
on le voit bien dans le sujet de simon
barbarie ce qui attend barack obama est
bien sûr encore la crise la crise est
encore là crise oui il a été réélu
probablement six mois après nicolas
sarkozy peut être que si nicolas sarkozy
a réussi moi il aurait été réélu comme
barack obama les choses vont un tout
petit peu mieux aux états unis même si
c'est extrêmement difficile ce qui est
formidable c'est seal enthousiasme qu'il
ya derrière cela quand barack obama dit
l'avenir est devant nous le meilleur est
devant nous c'est formidable et puis
quand on passe à l'interrogation du
président français impose sur l'élection
du président américain
et on retombe sur terre d'une façon un
peu un peu triste et pitoyable non on a
besoin d'un élan et un président comme
ça ça c'est donner un élan à notamment à
sa jeunesse c'est formidable ça donnait
envie ça donne envie d'un peu
actuellement le président du tout pas du
tout si c'est le contraire et c'est très
très regrettable c'est une gestion
étriquée des choses alors qu'au
contraire on a besoin d'une gestion
ouverte intelligente qui donne envie de
vivre en france et de projeter la france
dans l'avenir quand il ya mon dieu elle
un point commun qui est que barack obama
aura aussi les problèmes avec son
parlement son congrès lui il a pas la
majorité obama is débrouille en plus
sans majorité
hollande il a la majorité partout
partout à l'assemblée hocine harrouche
la chambre et au sénat dans les régions
dans les départements dans les grandes
villes jamais parti n'a eu autant de
pouvoir en france pour en faire quoi
aller mercredi encore environ dix jours
de l'élection à la présidence de votre
parti à l'ump on n'entendait plus trop
de petites phrases assassines entre pro
fillon et pro copé
en ce mercredi on a un peu rassuré parce
que valérie pécresse est invitée de la
presse parlementaire et padoue talent
est bien toujours comme vous du côté de
françois fillon interrogé sur
l'expérience de jean françois copé voici
ce qu'elle répond
c'est pas parce que j'allais dire on
n'est pas dans l'esbrouffe où on n'est
pas dans la vantardise qu'on ne fait pas
les choses vous savez et je le dis pas
par hope pas je je je ne savais pas je
ne dis rien sur jean françois copé en
disant ça je dis simplement que françois
fillon fait les choses il ne dit pas qui
va les faire il les fait et pour moi
c'est quand même plus rassurant de
d'imaginer que le pdt le président ma
formation politique à cette expérience
extraordinaire des combats difficiles
qui sont les combats des réformes
un peu embarrassé dans sa critique mais
quand même un inexpérimenté jean
françois copé non non vous joue pas je
veux pas jouer ce jeu là moi je soutiens
fillon parce que j'ai envie que ce soit
fillon je n'ai rien contre jean françois
copé il faut savoir gérer les débats au
sein de sa formation politique sinon y'a
plus jamais d'élection et je me dis moi
je me pose une question toute simple
aujourd'hui françois fillon si l'homme
politique de droite républicaine le plus
populaire en france je mets à côté
nicolas sarkozy ben voilà c'est une
chance de pouvoir le porter à la tête de
la première formation politique de
droite républicaine du pays c'est une
chance pour cette formation il ya
beaucoup de petites phrases toute façon
pendant cette campagne et même des
accusations de triche ou des
spéculations de triche pour apple la
peur c'est ça oui la peur de là pour
toujours si tu saisis dès que qu'il ya
toujours la peur de de triche moi je
crois je crois pas ça du tout je crois
la responsabilité des militants y aura
plein de bureaux de vote
ce qu'il faut c'est qu'il ya un maximum
de militants qui vote qu' un maximum de
bureaux de vote et des associations
c'est ça oui oui oui il faut qu'une
participation france au fil vue s'est
passé parce que c'est dans le cas
inverse pour c'est plutôt favorable à
jean françois copé
je pense que plus la participation est
élevée plus est favorable pour françois
fillon parce qu'il est plus rassembleur
en réalité eric woerth se débat de fond
est complètement inaudible on voit pas
bien la différence entre entre tout à
fait ce que vous dites
en général on voit bien que
jean-françois radicalise un peu le le
discours et les gens font soit par
exemple radicalise pas c'est plutôt des
petites phrases c'est là tout ça vous le
disais la semaine d'hommages à c'est la
même formation politique soit le sait
l'ump il n'y a pas de vie
radicalement différente de la société et
des mesures à prendre heureusement il ya
des postures il ya une personnalité qui
est différente une manière de le faire
mais moi je pense que le président de
l'ump
il doit ce que tu es à peu près au
milieu idéologique de de l'ump 1 au
centre de deux l'ump pas au centre de la
vie politique au centre de l'ump disent
qu'il faut rassembler les choses faut
rassembler ceux qui pensent très à
droite
il faut rassembler ceux qui pensent
trait au centre et ça le président de
l'ump doit le faire puis après derrière
il ya toutes celles et tous ceux qui
expriment leur sensibilité différente je
pense que fuyant le mieux placé copé et
françois fillon en ce moment les entends
un petit peu moins rapport sur la
compétitivité l'élection de barack obama
la semaine prochaine conférence de
presse de françois hollande
finalement cette élection de l'ump
n'intéresse pas grand monde
elle intéresse les militants l'ump je
faisais quand même très très important
c'est une élection
encore oui oui elle intéresse encore il
faut pas que ça dure trop longtemps
encore c'est très très utile que
l'élection ait lieu le 18 voilà une
belle campagne maintenant il faut il
faut que les militants votent ump est un
président que chacun travaille ensemble
et ressent on va passer au jeudi avec le
mariage pour tous qui arrive en
commission à l'assemblée nationale
le mariage homosexuel proposition numéro
31 du candidat hollande
il arrive en conseil des ministres sous
l'appellation mariage pour tous le texte
n'arrivera pas dans l'hémicycle avant la
fin janvier mais en attendant la
commission des lois a décidé d'organiser
des auditions sur le sujet la première
se tient ce jeudi est suivi par thibault
le floch confronter les points de vue
pour apaiser le débat
voilà l'objectif des auditions sur le
mariage et l'adoption aux couples
homosexuels
au programme 10 audition thématiques
avec des psychanalystes des
pédopsychiatres des familles
homoparentales
ou bien encore des associations qui
défendent les droits des homosexuels un
temps d'écouté avant le débat
parlementaire nécessaire selon le
président de la commission des lois on
voit bien qu'il ya des interrogations
on sociologique il ya l'intégration
psychiatrique des interrogations
une religieuse qui aujourd'hui montrent
une hostilité et donc j'ai souhaité avec
erwann binet qui est le rapporteur du
texte à la commission des lois que la
commission puisse largement prendre le
temps pour inviter tous ceux qui
représentent une opinion sur ce sujet
cet après midi les députés ont
auditionné trois sociologues
elles ont livré leur analyse sur la
structure familiale et le mariage
d'ailleurs selon elle le mariage pour
tous est une évolution logique de notre
société
c'est une grande loi en fait on fait un
peu l'histoire dit souvent on cite
beaucoup obama en ce moment mecque et
suez ont fait l'histoire
moi je suis persuadé qu'on ne reviendra
jamais en arrière que quand les gens
auront vu les mariages avec les gens sur
leur trente-et-un avec les familles avec
les grands parents
jamais on ne reviendra en arrière sur
cette loi un enthousiasme qui n'est pas
partagé par les représentants des cultes
et ils auront l'occasion de le dire aux
parlementaires lors de leur audition qui
aura lieu le 22 novembre prochain
donc avec verte vous n'êtes pas membre
de la commission des lois mais est-ce
que vous irez assister à certaines de
ces auditions oui je vais y aller parce
que je pense que ça intéresse absolument
tout le monde je n'aime pas d'ailleurs
le terme de mariage pour tous jeux pour
se galvauder l'institution du mariage en
effet protection socialement alors la
culture pour tous l'arrêt vers la
retraite pour tous voilà c'est fait je
ne sais pas répond sociaux je suis
opposé je suis opposé cette idée pas du
mariage en tant que tel je ne nie pas
que des personnes du même sexe puissent
s'aimer d'un amour profond jure je ne
juge personne n'y a aucune aucune notion
en dehors je n'ai aucune notion morale
là dedans je
bien loin de cela mais en même temps je
pense que ou comme beaucoup qui pensent
comme moi c'est que derrière le mariage
et surtout il ya la conjugalité mais la
parentalité donc il ya l'idée que on
élève un enfant que la nature la nature
la biologie a fait en sorte que tout ça
n'est d'une différence de sexe
qualifiant de cinq salles est majeure
elle fait fonctionner le monde
depuis toujours le monde animal le monde
humain le monde végétal enfin de la
planète sur laquelle on vit elle était
il ya un débat des représentants du
peuple assemblé à ce qu'il fallait un
débat plus ouvert des battles c'était
oui oui oui parce que c'est eux c'est
quand même pas un petit sujet qui est
qui celui au fond de deux de l'avenir de
nos enfants la réalité là je ne dis pas
qu un couple homosexuel ne lèvera pas
avec autant d'amour qu'un couple
hétérosexuel
mais je pense que c'est une changement
profond de société
moi je ne je ne crois pas qu'on puisse
jouer avec le feu dans ce domaine mais
c'est pas une raison
c'est pas une raison c'est pas une mais
c'est pas une raison c'est pas une
région on a le droit aussi d'avoir en
france nos propres opinions et je pense
que c'est pas ringard de penser qu'il
faut encore un homme et une femme a
ouvert et une mère pour élever dans de
bonnes conditions un enfant et qu'on n'a
pas le droit de jouer avec
avec cela on ne le fait pas sur des
sujets de moindre importance donc celui
là il faut faire très très attention si
la parentalité qui est au coeur de notre
combat moi je vais organiser un débat
chez moi à senlis ou à chantilly je
pense que je ferais sans liste pour pour
que chacun puisse s'exprimer
parce que je pense que c'est très
important s'il peut y avoir des
dérapages non de la pole pour les éviter
et je pense qu'aujourd'hui plus personne
ne juge le mot sexualité de deux
manières enfin il n'y a aucune morale
dans chacun à ce que j'ai dit et tout va
très bien j'ai aucun problème avec avec
ça j'ai un seul problème de dire qu'on
fonde la famille sur au fond qu'on gomme
la différence des sexes la différence
des sexes elle est inscrite au coeur de
notre planète
le maire de chantilly vous célébrerez
marier mais j'en sais rien parce que je
pense qu'il faut d'abord s'opposer au
texte
de toute façon
mairie elle respecte la loi et donc
c'est donc si elle garde des sceaux je
respecterai la loi de droit pour la
faire vous je sais pas je ne le ferai
pas avec plaisir mais je ne sais pas je
vais avec mes adjoints copé qui dirait
le verrai avec mes adjoints je veux pas
radicaliser les choses la loi est la loi
je me retrouve à combattre de façon très
forte
cette loi parce qu'on considère que
c'est pas une bonne évolution alors on
va passer sur un autre sujet on en
parlait déjà tout à l'heure les
communistes pose des problèmes au
gouvernement il se pose de plus en plus
la question est ce qu'ils sont dans la
majorité ou pas le premier ministre les
a reçus à matignon mais visiblement le
pré ministre a décidé de ne rien céder
sur la question c'est un récit de jérôme
rabin ils sont venus pour demander des
avancées sur les questions budgétaires
mais les communistes n'ont rien obtenu
du premier ministre
s'ils se sont félicités d'un dialogue
restaurer aucun accord sur le budget
2013 n'est venu sceller la rencontre
il est probable que nous ne votions
pauleta et que nous continuons à nous
abstenir mais nous ne désespérons pas de
convaincre que des débouchés
significatifs sont possibles sans
avancées significatives le budget 2013
et celui de la sécurité sociale risque
bien d'être retoqué au sénat et
rejoindre ainsi la loi de programmation
budgétaire rejeté hier soit par une
alliance de circonstance entre
communistes centriste et ump
au risque de laisser les mains libres à
l'assemblée nationale en faisant en
sorte que le sénat rejette les projets
du gouvernement les sénateurs
communistes rendent la main totalement
la main à l'assemblée nationale où la
majorité gouvernementale elle est solide
car constitutionnellement l'assemblée
nationale a le dernier mot en cas de
désaccord entre les deux chambres
parlementaires
mais tout le monde au sénat considère
qu'ils ignoraient la haute assemblée
aurait de graves conséquences et le
sénat n'aime pas les membres du
gouvernement qui donne le sentiment
peut-être parfois faussement mais qui
peuvent donner le sentiment par des
propos un peu hâtif et hasardeuse de
mépriser les sénateurs le sénat n'aime
pas ça au groupe socialiste on reconnaît
désormais un équilibre politique délicat
à conserver les communistes ne sont pas
socialistes et vice versa la palice
n'aurait pas dit mieux donc les
communistes ont des idées des
orientations à faire valoir
les socialistes en lot le gouvernement
prend ses décisions tranchera le premier
ministre arbitrera le parlement fera ce
qu'il a à faire et nous assumons les
choses mais attention si le sénat
continue de rejeter bon nombre de textes
portés par le gouvernement le risque
pour la haute assemblée serait d'être
réduite au silence forcé vous l'avez vue
d'un sujet au sénat est ce que vous
pensez que le gouvernement a mis
directement une croix sur le sénat
disant finalement ça va passer dans
l'opposition à stains quoique politique
d'envergure parce que le sénat ne sait
plus très bien où il est il est ni dans
la majorité ni dans l'opposition même si
on sait que la loi fait que l'assemblée
nationale a le dernier mot et bien sûr
c'est ce qu'a dit le ministre
cahuzac sap a visiblement beaucoup plus
aux sénateurs qui sont actives là dessus
will enfin nous on n'a pas eu de texte
rejeté par le par le sénat et ça
nécessite toujours beaucoup de
discussions koné glace je suis très à
droite donc j'ai pas prêt je vais les
choses je vis les choses mais enfin
entre la loi du flou entre la loi de
programmation budgétaire
on voit bien avec les moyens que les
communistes et c'est de plus en plus de
ceux de ceux de s'individualiser par
rapport par rapport au ceci parce que
sinon il n'existe plus et voilà et les
verts on en parlait tout à l'heure les
verts ce sera le deuxième problème il
arrivera tout de suite après les partis
communistes et peut-être même plus fort
que vous en terme d'opposition à partir
du moment où ils sont vous considérez
comme étant la ville ont voté françois
hollande
ils sont voter françois hollande au
deuxième tour donc françois hollande
doit faire un peu attention à eux j'ai
quand même des gens qui ont apporté
leurs voix
finalement non sont pas des alliés parce
que d'une certaine façon c'est souvent
pour des raisons contraires que nous ne
pouvons ne pas voter en même temps que
la loi de programmation budgétaire
moi c'est moi qui ai fait qu'ils aient
des lois programmation budgétaire
d'ailleurs c'est relativement récent la
loi de programmation budgétaire elle a
été elle n'a pas été voté par l'ump l'a
pas été voté par les par les communistes
pour des raisons différentes
évidemment mais n'a pas été voté au
socialiste aujourd'hui de recréer une
majorité et ce n'est pas en changeant de
cap tout le temps qu'ils vont réussir à
recréer une majorité moi j'ai pas de
conseiller leurs données entre nous mais
mais on voit bien on voit bien que tout
ça manque de direction on voit bien
qu'on sait pas où on va
en même temps ce n'est pas en allégeant
les charges des entreprises qui ne vont
s'allier les communistes ont clairement
non ils vont pas s'allier les
communistes en faisant ça et ils vont
passer liée non plus les verts en ne
traitant aucun des sujets qui les
préoccupent
la pression pas venir le rapport
galloires et une étude d'un cinglant
désaveu sur la politique énergétique de
2 du gouvernement à la fois sur
fessenheim et la fois sur le gaz de
schiste
justement que le parti socialiste est en
train de changer de logiciel comme on
dit qu'il devient un parti social
libéral presque je crois qu'il sait pas
du tout ce qui devient je pense qu'il
navigue à vue
donc je juge je ne le crois pas qu'il y
ait une ligne unique et très anti
entreprises
après on essaye de passer montebourg etc
après on essaye de passer un peu de jeu
de baume sur les plaies qu'on va créer
soi même c'est le c'est l'arroseur
arrosé il sans arrêt on est dans un pays
qui est un pays en crise comme
l'ensemble de l'europe et du monde
la france elle a une carte à jouer
maintenant à l'ap a une carte à jouer
dans deux ans dans trois ans dans quatre
ans on perd beaucoup de temps à
tergiverser tout le temps on va passer
au vendredi si vous voulez bien commencé
la semaine avec le rapport gallois et
ben on va finir avec le rapport j'ose
pas la commission sur la rénovation et
la déontologie de la vie publique
s'était mise en place en juillet dernier
présidé par lionel jospin et elle a
rendu son rapport ce vendredi les
propositions détaillées par rim benameur
fin du cumul des mandats l'introduction
de la proportionnelle sur tous les
sujets et lionel jospin a choisi de
suivre de près la lettre de mission
présidentielle
après quatre mois de travail les
conclusions de sa commission innove en
matière de vie politique c'est la
volonté de renforcer et parfois même de
rétablir la relation de confiance entre
les citoyens et les responsables publics
les citoyens sont au coeur de nos
propositions
parmi ces propositions l'introduction de
10% de proportionnelle aux élections
législatives
lionel jospin proposera aussi la fin du
système des 500 signatures
désormais 150 mille parrainage citoyen
seront exigés il suggère aussi de fermer
tous les bureaux de vote à 20 heures au
pré positionnés choc sur le statut pénal
du président désormais les actions qui
ne sont pas liées à sa fonction de chef
de l'état pourront être jugés en cours
de mandat et enfin l'une des mesures les
plus polémiques une limitation 13
stricte du cumul des mandats pour les
députés les sénateurs et les ministres
il sera désormais impossible de cumuler
avec des fonctions exécutives locales
c'est un enjeu essentiel pour la
rénovation de la vie publique
nous devons renoncer à cette exception
française
la commission a distingué à cet égard le
cas des ministres et celui des
parlementaires
un projet de loi devrait être présenté
au printemps 2013
mais les critiques s'élèvent déjà à
droite comme à gauche notamment sur le
cumul des mandats
les débats s'annoncent musclés alors
eric woerth pas de cumul des mandats
entre un parlementaire et un exécutif
local vous maire de chantilly vous
devriez démissionner de ce poste là en
tant que député j'attends les
conclusions définitives mais j'ai peur
que ce soit un peu du grand n'importe
quoi ces conclusions pour tout vous dire
de cette de cette commission qui n'a pas
n'a pas au fond de légitimité est très
très forte
je pense que être alors je vois bien que
c'est très démagogique je vois bien
qu'il ya beaucoup de français qui tape
sur les élus donc moins ils sont élus
mieux il se porte mais il n'y a pas de
démocratie sans s'en est lui je pense
qu'on peut fixer un seuil on peut se
dire qu'on peut pas être maire de nantes
et des députés par exemple on peut pas
être président peut pas être président
du conseil général de la corrèze et
député ça ça pose effectivement à terme
de prendre les députés
je pense qu'il faut fixer un seuil peut
être quinze mille 10000 20000 30me j'en
sais rien je veux pas faire de moi je
mets au coût moyen il ya un seuil
et puis ça va donner des députés qui
sont eux totalement technocratisme ça
qu'ils vont faire la loi est vraiment
limité à paris mais en même temps ils
vont être élus sur leur terrain donc
comment fait on est à la fois sur un
terrain on est à la fois législateur
mais on n'a pas le droit d'être élu en
réalité c'est un peu ça c'est un peu
curieux
c'est une drôle de manière de faire moi
je dis que si on veut aller jusque là
alors il faut pas uniquement faire sur
les exécutifs et quel rapport entre être
maire de paris et maire de la commune de
500 habitants aucun donc dans ce cas là
il faut faire le mandat unique et donc
il faut interdire tout cumul c'est à
dire dire on peut pas être conseiller
général et député on peut pas être
sénateur et conseiller général
on ne peut pas être conseiller régional
et sénateur peut pas être conseiller
régional et député à ce moment là quitte
à aller
quitte à faire n'importe quoi autant
aller au plus loin possible
le mandat unique la proportionnelle
grosse à peu près de 10% de taux
proportionnel sq qui voix pour et 58
députés
qu'est ce que vous en pensez à lionel
jospin était battu par le front national
il réintègre le front national
totalement dans le jeu politique en
faisant cela comme il va réintégrer le
front de gauche jeu
je ne sais pas je pense que c'est pas
une très bonne idée je pense qu'au fond
la vème république
elle a très bien fonctionné l'a
magnifiquement fonctionner elle s'est
adaptée s'étalant de moteur noyé dans la
modernité c'est pas de changer en
faisant n'importe quoi ou en cédant à la
démagogie la plus ultime
la modernité c'est que c'est d'avoir des
textes qui vous permettent d'agir sur le
fond là on parle de forme mais d'agir
sur le fond et la vème république elle
est solide ce qu'a voulu le général de
gaulle le mille morts le 9 novembre
celle qu'a voulu le général de gaulle
cesser cette république là et cela elle
a bien tenu donc faisons attention à
toutes ces modifications au fond qui
conduisent
je pense à fragiliser le cadre de nos
institutions il faut faut manier avec
une main tremblante la constitution je
relance d'ailleurs pardon juste je
remarque quand même que ceux qui sont le
plus opposés au cumul
sachant que le cumul des mandats il et
il est limité à 2 1 il est limité à deux
les plus opposés sur ce qui en général
ont loupé des élections locales c'est ce
qu'ils ont été battus certes les
premiers à dire il faut pas de cursus
des premiers à être incapable de ce
faire il ya quelque part des dons qui
coûtait amertume et colère qui à mon
avis n'est pas une bonne manière de
réforme pénale notamment pour pour le
président pourquoi pas sauf que le
président de la république il a un
statut l'ajustement qui lui permet de
rester le premier des français le plus
longtemps possible
je trouve qu'il faut faire aussi
attention à cela
attention quand même attention des 500
parrainages maintenant 1500 personnes
pourront signer est-ce qu'il faut rendre
publiques les 100 ciels 5000 francs 50
personnes ça va à développer le nombre
de candidatures aux élections
présidentielles je suis pas sûr qu'on
ait besoin d'avoir autant de
candidatures que cela peut-être
aurait-on pu faire autrement je ne sais
pas moi tout ça me semble au fond assez
assez dérisoire c'est vraiment pas le
sujet aujourd'hui je ne vois pas oui oui
c'est pas un sujet très prieuré pas
d'urgence notre démocratie elle
fonctionne pas si mal et pourtant si
l'on interroge les gens notamment sur le
cumul des bourdes à tout le monde
applaudit doué mais si on leur demande
sur leur pharmacien gagnent trop
d'argent selon demande sur l'a6 leurs
voisins a pas une trop grosse voiture ce
sera aussi des réponses un peu étonnante
donc je crois pas qu'il faille se fonder
nécessairement sur l'opinion
statistiques
à un moment donné je remarque que 90 des
français il aime bien leurs élus il
trouve que ils font bien leur boulot
quand c'est leurs élus qui mettent un
nom dessus
et puis d'une manière générale la classe
politique comme partout dans le monde
elle souffre évidemment de critiques
absolue mais c'est au fond la démocratie
mais attention à trop affaiblir les élus
on affaiblit la démocratie n'est en tout
cas il y aura un projet de loi début
2013 donc on aura largement auquel un
verger loi en 2013 vous avez remarqué
j'ai jamais vu ainsi contre le fait
beaucoup de temps ici à l'assemblée
certainement gmx est une c'est une bonne
chose si ces projets de loi sont utiles
la crise et eric woerth d'avoir répondu
aux questions pendant cette petite heure
et nous avec michael on se retrouve